during the purge all crime is legal so
this isn't even a question right you
should definitely be able to steal stuff
the answer isn't that simple
if you purge someone during the purge
the whole act is concluded before the
purge ends but the purge season 2
shows us that if you're still on private
property after the conclusion of the
last siren
they can book you for trespassing so
what if you steal something are you
required to drop it before the end of
the final siren is it considered
possession of stolen property the moment
the 12 hours of the purge have elapsed
if you're watching this on the day of
upload happy purge to each and every one
of you my initial plan for today's
festivities was to upload my things you
missed episode on the purge tv series
however that's gonna take a little bit
longer but i couldn't leave you with no
purge video on purge night
so before you head out there and do your
own purging it's best to know and
understand the rules i've been seeing
this question a lot in my comments
lately if you steal something during the
purge
do you get to keep it the answer is
sometimes
[Music]
to answer this question let's look back
at the things that have been stolen
during the purge
in the original movie mrs sandon hangs
onto the polite stranger's rifle after
his purge but
dante bishop gives back the gun that he
acquired from the sand ins
though this could just be because the
family had already lost so much and he
wasn't gonna take anything else
in anarchy leo cali and eva steal
weapons and a vehicle from the woman who
hosted the purge gala leo leaves the
girls in the car while he goes to take
care of business but he's critically
injured
just before the purge ends before the
siren sound eva and cali get out of the
car to go aid him but they hang on to
the guns
it's safe to say at this point that the
stolen guns can be kept but when they're
trying to get leo to the hospital they
don't seem to consider
using the stolen car they were just in
he got a car
[Music]
so they use this guy's car to get leo to
the hospital it seems like cars cannot
be kept if stolen during the purge
we don't see anything else get stolen
during anarchy but we can learn more
from this line
so quiet here this district's always
quiet on purge night the banks move
their money
no one's ever down here the fact that
the banks move their money suggests that
there is an incentive for someone to try
to rob the bank which does happen in a
later installment
we'll get to that next is election year
the main story ends just after midnight
so we never actually see the end of that
purge however there is an item that is
attempted to be stolen
and i want my candy bar and i'm gonna
take it
yeah kimmy tries to steal a candy bar i
think we can all agree it's no surprise
that this would be allowed especially if
you eat it before the purge ends marcos
comes back at the conclusion and finds
the whole deli ransac so it seems likely
that any food items are fair game to
keep after the purge regardless of if
they're eaten another note to make about
election year it takes place in the
future and dante is still easily able to
hotwire a car which he only uses for a
moment before his death
but my takeaway from this is that it's
not difficult to steal a car
so the fact that the purge hasn't become
a free-for-all for every parked car on
the street must mean that you can't keep
a vehicle if you steal one
the fourth movie is the prequel the
first purge this time we actually get to
see a couple robberies take place
one man attempts to pry open an atm
machine if you're not allowed to keep
the money that you steal during the
purge he has no reason to be out there
risking his life we also see a group of
thieves target a cash for gold store
i'm exercising my right to purge by
taking all your merch and if you stand
in my way i will [ __ ]
you
this place has jewelry guns gold and
silver they're stealing more valuable
items which tells me that what can and
cannot be kept isn't so much related to
the price tag
so far it seems like cars cannot be kept
post purge but any items small enough to
hold in your hand are fair game
including money what about larger sums
of money or larger objects while the
purge season 1 doesn't have much
thieving going on
season 2 introduces us to a band of bank
robbers what happens is
interesting three of them make it out of
the bank before the purge ends and they
get to keep their money but tommy gets
caught with his foot on the line as time
expires and they book him for armed
robbery however they later find out that
the amount that they stole wasn't
actually that much because the banks are
keeping most of their money in an
airplane throughout the entire duration
of the purge so next purge they come up
with a plan to prevent the plan from
taking off and taking a haul
upward of 100 million dollars proving
that the value of products stolen is not
a factor
the money is kept in these huge rolling
cases which they unload from an armored
truck onto their boat
this has me convinced that the size of
an item isn't necessarily relevant here
either their plan was always to stop the
plane from taking off
they'd never seem to consider hijacking
the plane maybe there are practical
reasons that they couldn't do that but
the fact stands that the idea of trying
to stow away in one of these cases and
take control of the plane is never even
brought up which leads me to believe
that planes are also off limits
but there is perhaps an even more
important detail that i noticed in
season 2 that answers another previously
unknown question
what about houses can you take over
someone's house or business purge the
inhabitants and claim it as your own
property
season two storyline revolves around the
death of a character named drew adams
her friend
esme stops by her house after she's gone
and encounters two real terms
i'm so sorry we're just doing a first
inspection did you want to look around
are you thinking of buying the owner was
just purged and uh we think it's gonna
go very fast it would appear that if a
person is purged their home can't be
claimed instead it just goes on the
market
this is kind of a dark detail the nffa
can just purge people and turn a huge
profit on their house so you can't keep
real estate or vehicles if you steal a
car have fun on your joy ride but you
better be out of it by 7 am
same goes for real estate but you can
keep other items or money no matter how
big
no matter how valuable so what is the
logic behind these rules
i think i have the answer
all crime is legal during the purge you
cannot go back and try to arrest someone
after the purge for a crime that was
committed during the purge however if
that crime is still happening when the
purge concludes it's considered an
off-purge crime that's why tommy is
arrested for being at the bank if i
steal five dollars from you it's my
money now as long as i steal it
during the purge money weapons jewelry
food and other common items are
transferred by hand-to-hand exchange
for example if you give someone a cookie
it's assumed that you're giving them
ownership
even if it's agreed that they're just
borrowing the cookie it's ultimately
gonna be on them to return it
you voluntarily gave the cookie to them
so no crime was committed even if they
don't give it back
however that's not how you transfer
vehicles or real estate
if i wanted to transfer ownership of my
car to you which i don't what do i look
like david dobrik i'd have to fill out a
title certificate
sign it and go to the local dmv to
officially transfer the ownership the
dmv is not open during the purge so
transferring ownership is impossible
meaning that when i wake up on march
22nd the car still belongs to me no
matter what happened in the last 12
hours
even if the car title is stolen the dmv
has a duplicate which they can still
give a copy of to the legal owner
for a small fee there is a similar
process for transferring real estate
once again you have a title as proof of
your legal ownership you need to get a
real estate attorney who will prepare
the deed
the legal document that transfers
ownership of the property you'll need to
sign
the deed in front of a notary a public
officer who is not available on purge
night
these processes also apply to aircrafts
boats trailers businesses and
probably submarines i mean i didn't look
it up but i'm guessing submarines so the
purge isn't useful
for stealing these kind of items now you
may be wondering okay what if i just use
the purge to steal a car hide it in a
garage and then sell it off the record
for cash or for parts
sure you'd be committing a crime but
because there are no emergency services
during the purge there's a good chance
you'd get away with it
well that's not so easy either the purge
takes place in the future and we already
have modern vehicles that are
practically impossible to steal with
two-factor authentication
however based on how easily dante hacks
into the car in election year let's just
assume that criminals have evolved as
fast as auto security
even then you're not going to get very
far dante drove the car all of 20 feet
before getting purged with gps tracking
stolen cars are becoming a thing of the
past
even if you're an experienced hacker and
managed to disable this
good luck relocating the car when nearly
every street in america is covered by
cameras and watched over by a team of
nffa surveillance agents
so your best bet is going after that
cold hard cash
or a candy bar man's gotta eat if you
have other questions about the purge
drop a comment and maybe i'll answer in
a future video
check out my purge playlist on the left
and remember to subscribe to cz's world
for new horrors every week ring the
death bell for all notifications and
i'll
see you in the next purge assuming we
both survive
if you don't want to get purged stay
home if you have to go out for
essentials wear a mask